I want to let you know about some new
shows that are coming out right now
Toronto we've just added a Late Show on
February 21st February 15th the Gold
Country Casino in Oroville California
those tickets are on sale now still
available January 14th in Oslo Norway
Las Vegas January 31st and February 1st
I will be at the Mirage Hotel and Casino
those tickets are a little higher price
than usual it's because it's a specialty
weekend and that was the that was the
agreement that the theater would do with
me
so if it's too high price for you that's
understandable I'll be back in the
future at a more decent rate and also I
want to let you know February 28th in
Oxon Hill Maryland at the MGM National
Harbor
today's guest is is a working man he is
this is one of my favorite episodes and
we're so glad that he was here he is a
plumber and a regular man ladies and
gentlemen the toilet champion is here
plumber Brad Laskowski
[Music]
we're here with bread Laskowski and
that's polish huh oh yeah Polish power
dude and thanks for joining us today
thanks for having me we uh yeah just
happy to talk to a poorer man cuz I
don't know anything really about
plumbing
can I ask away you know um all right
I'll think about this so what is the
difference between plumbing and septic
tank I was thinking about that all right
like some time you hear like you know
you hear people have septic tanks I
would hear a lot of times growing up
people had septic tanks you know or
somebody got like sure you know um
something happened to him by a septic
tank that's how I actually got my start
was of dealing with septic tanks I
started twenty something years ago with
roto-rooter I'm sure you heard of them
oh yeah and that's a commercial outfit
isn't a largest plumbing company in the
world
is it really yep Wow so yeah the very
first day I get hired I gotten out of
the army I was 20 years old I get hired
with this roto uh-huh
my brother I wrote a rooter-man in a lab
where they in and were they are
enlisting people in I mean it was not
like a program from the Army to rotary
no no no no no no I don't know I got out
of the Army and I went to work at Lowe's
the home improvement store oh yeah I
love that yeah I was actually when I got
out of the army I was 20 and I had
applied to Atlanta SWAT and I was going
through all the SWAT qualifications and
everything else cuz I was I was kind of
heavy duty in the military you know so
it really have a whole lot of skills
when I got out how did you get out at 20
I I joined when I was 17 so I graduated
early you know a little smart you know
yeah
figured some stuff out and and hard work
and you must have been huh very still am
yeah most people will call me the
hardest worker they ever met dang so I
kind of take that as a point of pride
you know I could see that you're like
the Joe Rogan a plumbing dude because
you're Hogan is I think it's the hardest
worker that guy is busy did I think
there's not there has to be more than
one because he's in too many places at
once
sometime I have a I have like out of a
day dream where he's gonna bring me in a
room
I want you to meet these other Joe okay
so you get out of the military so that's
a note for young fellas if you like I
don't know if I could go on the military
17 out by 20 yeah yeah Wow yeah I can I
use my VA benefits
you know I everything's cool
everything's like normal yeah I just I
joined earlier I got out her I signed up
for three I got out yeah so they offered
to reenlist me but I I had just met this
girl and she was just pregnant you knows
young you get a right energy with now
she was pregnant when you met her yeah
Wow it's a brave deal I stuck on with
that crap for seven years to with her
and her kid well we eventually had one
to her okay like a few years later her
and I might be my little area yeah all
right and then divorce 27 left anyway
the point of the septic thing was dude
that hires me is old go fat dude from
Alabama you know southern and as as all
can be yeah take you out on your first
day you'll see it's not that bad
and we go out and dig up a septic tank
which is plump we'll hide em or what but
they're always buried oh so so so the
pipe that leaves your house goes
underground and it goes out to a box in
the yard and that it basically naturally
decomposes everything that's in there
okay so it's compost almost kind of an
away yeah yeah but it's it's it's a big
it's it's five feet deep it's it's a big
box you could bury a lot of bodies in
there good you could and it's so it's
five feet deep and it's buried in the
ground yeah usually a foot deep maybe
more okay and and and it's foul is it
square it's a it's about like this table
you know it's a big long rectangle maybe
a little wider or so about five feet
deeper so I saw a dude weld one and a
half one time I remember some of they're
usually concrete uh well then this got
kind of I guess welded it with like a um
maybe a concrete sure
well he might he used to he might have
had a steel box because I mean you I've
seen some rustic septic tanks made out
of 55-gallon drums with holes punched in
the side okay so you see some rural ones
I've seen you seen them I I've seen you
see if I can the Noah's Ark a [ __ ]
in-ground [ __ ] you better believe it
in Alabama they'll do whatever it takes
oh yeah I went to one house in Alabama
they didn't even have a septic tank
the pipe went down it went out about a
hundred yards and that was it a while it
just left out on the ground Wow
yeah roots were all growing up into the
end of the pipe and everything so I had
to go there and cut them all off and
open it out and snake the pipe out and
get everything good to go and everything
so
but that's no septic tank yeah just a
long pipe just freelance old school
it's illegal it is yeah Blackwater needs
to be contained okay so that's really
the rule yeah Blackwater has to be
contained brown water or gray water like
kitchen sink water and washing machines
dishwashers stuff like that you can
actually and I do install a 55-gallon
drum with a pump in it and separate
those lines from a septic tank okay so
all that washing machine water that's
bad for a septic tank now goes into a
55-gallon drum with a pump in it and
then you can water your yard with that
okay so that's a washing machine water
that gray water yeah you can take that
into a drum yeah if you wanted to yeah
and then reuse that it's actually good
because it's got soap in it and soap and
the phosphates are good for your grass
oh wow yeah your figure so that's so but
the dark water the black black water has
to be by law has to be contained contain
yeah and then what do you do after you
contain it well in a septic tank system
after a couple of years all that stuff
breaks down and separates the solids
will sink to the bottom and turn to a
sludge the things that are not
biodegradable little a wedding ring or
something of a dog you know that
anything that would sink will go to the
bottom obviously but anything that's
grease won't biodegrade it'll collect
and it'll turn into a ball basically a
hard kind of crust on the top of the
septic tank water or condoms won't
biodegrade they'll float oh wow man one
time I popped a septic tank open and I
saw about 10,000 condoms in there I
swear I mean I didn't count them or
anything but they were all over the top
of Italian who was the guy a little
Asian guy no no it was that the
homeowner him he was standing there
watching me dig this tank huh right so I
have kids it's like was no chance no oh
yeah cuz they weren't his condoms no way
I could have guessed it was a homeowner
yeah he was standing there watching me I
popped up well he called me because the
his his toilet wouldn't flush no more
right now get there and I snake the
drain huh
and and it won't go down I'm like well I
got to dig up your tank so I dig up the
tank and when I open up the tank and you
look down they're just everywhere their
coat in the wall two pink ones and green
ones and mom I mean every color of the
racist Easter colors oh yeah dude worked
at a tire manufacturing plant the
graveyard shift for like 20 years and
I'm betting every night
no she had somebody coming they got a
divorce
so you really is it so that's man that's
crazy
sometimes opening up that sector tank
it's almost like a time capsule for your
blood or almost or so for your you know
for below the waist it's almost like a
time capsule for which you or anything
you've been doing in your home totally
yep yeah I mean that that actually
happened twice that instance caused a
divorce the next time that happened
where I found condoms in the tank it was
a young girl she was like 14 or 15 was
her grandma's house oh and the grandma
was standing there watching me and whose
were they you think there were two
granddaughters for sure oh good I mean
they were it was just a those are the
only two ladies living in houses -
fourteen-year-old girl and the ground
and the grandma is like a mine that's
gonna be awkward game a go fish that
they play later in the rain
where'd you get all these why are they
in here uh so that's why it's you
started in Alabama yeah you worked in a
man do you remember the gentleman the
guy who hired me oh absolutely we still
talk oh that's cool yeah he's a good man
he is now when you what was like your
vibe when you started working there were
you like it were you like oh this is a
career that I want to make or were you
like this is just a job that I want to
do what was kind of your your goal if
you had any going into it you know where
the money I didn't really have a goal
going into it the money just sticks you
plum and pays well yeah and it always
has so and they say I've heard this is a
saying in the universe that plumbers
make more than lawyers I believe that
you do and how does that break down
because why lawyers ain't working 40
hours a week right you know what I mean
they get paid a lot for what they do but
they don't do it all the time right so
that's great that they get $400 an hour
three hours a week right you know I work
50 60 hours a week every week right and
you know I'm only charging 100
maybe more or whatever but but you add
it up over time it up that's what I do
it yet because you always hear that you
always hear that lawyer that plumbers
make more than lawyers that's the second
thing I've always heard or doctors know
yeah I heard it as doctors but I mean
same thing I went to a university
professors house years ago and and I
handed in the bill at the end and he
just flipped out like he was just
couldn't believe it cost that much you
charge more than doctors do do you
realize it took me ten years to learn
how to do this right you know it
literally is a 10-year program you know
it's it's as hard I think of course
because I went down that road as any
eight-year doctorate or master's degree
that you're gonna get it will come okay
yeah I mean anything you're gaining
knowledge yeah so that's some
well-rounded plumber anyway yeah and so
you start this job you got the guy with
roto-rooter yeah and so you worked there
for how long with that guy for five
years
little over five years do gave me $1,000
bonus for every year I work for did he
really
so second year was too grand third years
three fifth year was five and [ __ ] man
well that's God working right here
because dude needs a little bit of help
right this is a hard worker he's the
hardest work right now it was very hard
and he really is meant woke him up and
he's very good at that
yeah I agree with you Hey all right we
do our best Lawson I saw him one of your
other shows you were talking about if it
came down to killing him or killing you
you might not even kill him yeah that's
a pretty big step
I forgot I said that but I still agree
with us okay so and also with plumbing
you if it's like if it's a holiday then
those prices are higher right you have
to do it don't you when I was working
for the commercial companies yeah I say
they did now that I I I actually quit
doing that working for commercial
companies mostly because I was tired of
hearing the complaints from the
customers about how much it cost
oh really you know I'm going and doing
the work
I'm getting paid from the company right
not very much okay not as obviously not
as much as now yeah but I mean you got
to understand any large company they got
overhead they got you know insurances
that are humongous yeah just
advertisement calls for having a place
do my Ellen I just for myself as almost
twenty grand a month
well her a year a year and if I had to
add on like an apprentice or something
it doubles right that's wild isn't it
that's why I do everything by myself
right you know it's interesting yeah
it's like you got to get um yeah I just
realized we have to get a policy in case
anything like errors and omissions
policy we have to get for podcasting now
you have to get workman's comp
yeah um and EPL and I are some similar
type of policy that I just that they
just sent me something for the other day
that's like I don't even a [ __ ] four
days so it's like but it's interesting
yeah once you start to if you want to
build something bigger yeah or add more
more there's more costs and liabilities
that error incurred and they say you
know California is the hardest place to
tirana either a small business or to get
get a startup going yeah there's so many
restrictions and so many fees and and
and regulations that govern it's crazy
it was named ah it's like what's even
going on here when I was in Hawaii I was
rolling in money yeah just so didn't
have to worry about nothing now how do
you um how do you plumb in Hawaii
because slower
everything's slower well it seems like
you have like all the water pushing on
the island it's gonna push everything
back up the toilet they I mean their
infrastructures you know significantly
improved from way back those days you
know everything's built up everything's
feet off the ground and all that they
have sanitary sewer systems which is
which is the name for you you call it
sanitary sewer I don't know why because
it's not [ __ ] sanitary at all it is
it
there's turds floating down this pipe
that leaves this building it's called
the sanitary sewer line okay
it's full of turds it's not sanitary in
any way I have no other they don't know
everybody's everybody in the building
you know everybody in the bill
like [ __ ] nose dildo has one great big
pipe that leaves it from all the smaller
pipes that come from each toilet okay
they all join together and make one big
pipe that pipe goes out to the street
which is a bigger pipe probably twelve
fourteen twenty four inches who knows
city like this is probably big okay and
all the turds are floating down that
okay it's a constant stream it looks
like a river if you were to open up a
manhole in the street and look down
there it's a constant stream and that's
of like water
yeah that's black vodka contained that's
contained but they call it sanitary and
in my whole life at plumbing 25 years or
whatever it's always been called
sanitary sewer yeah why I think probably
give people a safe idea just like oh so
in case they see the pipe they're like
oh yeah it's yeah we're doing our best
it's sanitary it's down there yeah it's
out of the way it's sanitary it's hidden
so all that goes to a sewer treatment
facility where they process and treat it
and then release the clean water into a
stream and out to the ocean okay and is
it really clean when it gets out there
you can be honest it passes EPA
standards right we'll leave it at that
you know I wouldn't drink it I wouldn't
drink any of the water near it what if
you made an ice tray cube of trays or
like an ice of it would you put one cube
like in a soda or sock no no you got him
you got to get a little more polis in
that man I have been around enough turds
in my life and have you after like 11
years of that I had to give up on the
roto-rooter thing and in the
roto-rooter's deals mostly with with
feces now what is that let me ask you
what's the term that's comfortable to
use like because every time if a plumber
comes over I don't know if I say [ __ ] do
I say poop do I say turds do I whatever
you like man okay whatever you like you
know it they all work I I had this guy
in Alabama one time I die I knock on the
door and everything you know roto-rooter
man I'm here and he opens the door and
he goes thank god you're here man I've
been fighting these turds all morning
and I go in there and he's got just
water sprayed up all over the walls he's
been plunging the [ __ ] out of this
toilet for like an hour and making no
headway
oh I said give me that and I take the
dudes plunger and he goes that ain't
gonna work you're gonna need some way
more than that and I put it in there and
hit it like two three times pop it goes
away how the [ __ ] do you do that man I'm
I do this for a living this is what I do
do some people um like if he is it
uncomfortable I feel like it's
uncomfortable if you go into a place
does the guy do you like
does somebody be like okay I pooped in
here does people just like vague about
it hey somebody [ __ ] in here no time
sometimes people are super embarrassed
and like I'm really sorry about it
that's how I would be yeah I would too
hey if it were me I'd get the turd out
yeah I mean if I didn't know what to do
I'm right put it on a paper something
running outside it's not here yeah fish
ghupat whatever you got I mean I've seen
some rose petals and III can't call this
lady out she probably dead by now anyway
but I used to have this one customer it
was the sweetest nicest lady I went to
her house probably three years you know
constantly I was going to her house like
every month once a month I'd go to her
house and unstop bolta her toilets hmm
because I know this little graphic but
she would [ __ ] baseballs oh wow really
just round balls of [ __ ] if you I'm not
sure what was going on with her
intestines we used to talk about it the
roto-rooter guys yeah like what's up
with this lady how does this happen
he's got the Walker Buehler : right they
go Joe Musgrove I'm wondering if she's
[ __ ] baseballs how fast did they
come out you know could we clock these
things oh it must be so intense is it
like a curveball slider look it's
probably a slide probably uh it's
probably a slider my head so anyway they
would clog the toilet and so and you get
in there and what so you if you can't
hit it with a plunger which these turds
were solid man they were back they were
well built turns and do you think she's
eating something
she is she whatever her diet is is
creating this last maybe like paste turn
you could so we had a snake for the
toilet right that you stick in the
toilet non-stop it'll grab things to
this snake would like go through the
turd and just put a little hole in it
and then once you pull the snake out
it's like the turd would close back up
like jello the turd would just close
back like it's herminator like yeah like
the like the liquid Terminator you so
you'd you'd basically just have to run
that snake back and forth and back and
forth to tell you could break up enough
of that turd to get the water helping it
out to flush this thing all the way
through how far does that roto-rooter
thing go that one would only go through
the toilet like four or five feet Oh was
it just right - yeah cuz the toilet will
go down and then up and then down again
and that's about three feet by the time
it finishes okay that's really all you
need right cuz if it's any farther than
that you need to pull the toilet off the
floor and go after the pipe okay you
know I'm saying so at that point yeah
you once you do after that three feet
you're going into into the pipe into the
sewer system it's a different ballgame
yeah it gets a little more expensive
after that usually okay so um and why
does the pipe on the toilet go up and
down like that after that would seem
like a straight pipe would help out
better it's a trap it has to go down and
up like that so water always stays in
that portion right there otherwise
you're gonna smell ship coming out of
there out of the pipe all the time that
that water there prevents the smell from
coming back ah so that's why I has that
kind of snake that s curvy trap the P
trap yeah same thing underneath your
sink you see that little you bend
underneath right the event it stinks but
it's up and it's stuck in the top part
of that pipe well anything downstream of
that where that water is smells really
bad I say that water is what blocks the
gas sewer gas from coming back at you oh
yeah you ever go into a building and it
just kind of smells like [ __ ]
the a a the whole place smells like
sewer and you can't figure it out
usually what that is is a dry floor
drain somewhere because floor drains
even in the bathrooms they have that
same p trap in the bottom of them but if
nobody pours water in them that will
evaporate here's a free tip for like
everybody out there that'll evaporate
and then you'll get that sewer gas smell
there's no water there to block it from
corral so a lot of times you just I mean
so many times I'd walk into a building
and I know that smell well yeah we got
to smell we don't know oh yeah I know it
and then I just search around and find
the dry floor drain pour some water in
there and give me my money
yeah but mouths right so a lot of this
probably over the years you learn these
different ways of like okay instead of
you know going through every pipe in the
building the first time to the
thousandth time you come in it's to
smell you find the dried range room and
I'm done oh man yeah you know after 20
years of the experience pays tons it
really does any should way and it should
because you put in the time so is there
certain points where uh like do you feel
Oh interrupt you about the story with
that lady or was that it she just had
some wild she's just had wild turds man
we used to talk about we would never you
know shame her embarrassing just go
there and take care of it was sorry you
know give us call when you need us
we gave her a super discounted rate
because she called us all the time right
eventually and she used to give that the
first lady that I married they their kid
that the daughter that she had that
wasn't mine right was uh she used to
give that girl presents little dolls and
stuff so she's almost like you know the
family a little community and yeah
here's for your daughter you know yeah
so after like three years of feeling
guilty on stopping this lady's toilet
every month look on my day off
I'm gonna come over and I'm gonna
install you to pressure assisted power
toilets for free dang you pay for the
toilets I'll give you the labor for free
and I went over there on a Saturday I
jerked her old toilets out that were you
know obviously not up to the challenge
she was putting on them and and and put
in these you've seen that Body Works he
liked those jet toilets where he flushed
him they just sound like a jet engine
going on yeah I put two of those in she
never called us again Wow
fixed good to go she did call us like a
year later because their kitchen sink
was stopped up or something like that
but how many thousands of dollars did
that just say over the lifetime of all
that you have to do that every once in a
while yeah every year you help out man
you help out where you can especially
noticed those patterns yeah you know
you're like at some point it does get to
be like oh um yeah I'm keep giving this
person this person keeps giving me
business but a certain point I can just
be helpful or something man you almost
feel like you're robbing them out yeah
yeah I like having that thing inside of
you that feels like that because then it
tells you when I like be one way and
when to be another way
and that's why I do it by myself now I
can't do it for a company they charge
too much and so you did roto-rooter for
how long eleven years and that was in
Alabama no no I five years in Alabama
and six years in Tacoma in Seattle oh
wow yeah so when I got divorced in
Alabama I moved to Washington which is
where I was born and that's higher
altitude and people are DC level though
it is yeah I was right on the water
right right in Seattle there's sea level
yeah I just feel like overall Nick we
just looked at up and I'm not
challenging I'm just curious myself is
is Seattle what the difference in land
elevation is for some reason I always
think of the South as being like a lower
I I'm not sure what it was in Alabama
but when I was in Alabama I want to say
they were a couple hundred feet up where
Seattle is I mean there's water right
there right in front of you right that
water is sea level because it's the
Puget Sound oh yeah that's the dang sea
yeah you're right so but base elevation
Alabama probably a couple hundred feet
maybe Oh
five hundred feet above sea level there
you go mean elevation they found highest
point in Seattle is 520 feet yeah you
got some hills for sure but the lowest
point which is sea level Wow gang
average elevations 170 all right so
anyway so yeah that's a lot where you're
driving around the Pacific Northwest
Seattle and all the surrounding areas
a lot of the area you're looking at
water right the sound out there so not
elevation so much but cold rainy wet
grey and how does that affect plumbing
like is there different type of plumbing
going on that's what I want to know is
there different plumbing going on in the
Pacific Northwest that we don't know
about or something as opposed to what's
going on like an Alabama in Alabama the
rules so when I was in Alabama they ran
off the national plumbing code which is
a book about
three quarters of an inch thick or so
got a lot of pages in it maybe a hundred
pages or so national plumbing code
pretty simple do what you want as long
as it works basically and don't leak
right I moved to Washington and they as
as California does now - but back then
they did a uniform plumbing code which
is the gold standard and that book is
like this thick and it's got a den
addendums and additions and response in
Constitution or science I got it's
unreal a see it's everything out west
once you get out here there's so much
paperwork and this and that and you
gotta and nobody if somebody doesn't
want to work at all you got a fee you
got a [ __ ] bomb I've had more all
that the farther west you go the harder
it is on the working man yeah it really
is so they say Washington's the hardest
state to get a license in for plumbers
Michigan's the second hardest really
yeah you'd think people would be doing a
lot of [ __ ] in Michigan and they would
need more help
that's what it's all their [ __ ] freezes
oh really you know I mean they have all
I'm even thinking about that dude
imagine now it's frozen frozen [ __ ] you
got a whole different path you can't run
a sewer cable through frozen [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do you do do restrictions are
different and cold weather climates I
I've never been to Michigan but I'm
gonna guess that they're gonna be
somewhere similar as to like Colorado
and I did do Colorado plumbing Wow and
all their shits buried eight feet deep
in Colorado
oh all of their septic tanks and
everything's buried ate all the
plaughter lines everything the rule yeah
eight feet deepest to keep it warm
enough yeah to keep it from freezing Wow
yep interesting huh Washington is 24
inches so two feet deep I think
California is 18 inches in Louisiana I
think is just right out the window based
Alabama was ground level was it yep one
inch deep yeah just don't let your
lawnmower hit it Wow and yeah cuz I
remember they had like a neighbor when I
was growing up that they would just they
had like a [ __ ] line and just went off
into the woods advantages and then at a
certain point on where we ran back there
and when you're kids you don't know you
think it's like a little
her like a little lake or something so
yeah people are jumping around skipping
rocks off of [ __ ] yeah just you know I
make him little boat who used to make
little school boats and like push him
out and like this like kind of duty
canal Cana just hey you here kid you
sick now uh I'm not doing great but I'm
doing this year I'm feeling okay
but generally speaking throughout your
whole life
are you a healthy dude yeah me too
you know why why because you played with
[ __ ] yeah you've got dirty every once in
a while you can give a crap about
washing your hands every single time you
went to the bathroom
oh yeah out here like everybody that I
saw some woman get a bunch of hand
sanitizer and wash her son's neck with
it the other day and when I was at the
bank I can't be good for him though that
kid's gonna [ __ ] get hit by lightning
yeah it's definitely it can't be good
for you yeah just letting that alcohol
soak into your skin like that yeah and
just like at a certain point everything
has Dominico diminishing returns
diminishing returns everything does it's
like okay you want to get so clean and
everything then fine you know something
small comes along a breeze but a little
bit of cigarette smoke in it and now you
a kid can't [ __ ] see for two years I
know Carlin said some stuff years ago
about you know you you spend so much
time washing this and scrubbing that and
making sure you're so clean that when
something real does come along your
immune system is not going to be
prepared for it yeah and you're gonna
die your immune system is that like a
four-star restaurant or something yeah
yeah it's a little bit like a comes in
you can't [ __ ] handle it right you
gotta build it up you gotta do something
to kind of strengthen your immune system
somehow so yeah go play with some turns
every once in a while Amen bro look I'd
watch people do it yeah I know it's
yourself Mario made you do it
uh oh yeah dude when I was young they
had a kid in my neighborhood used to
make me berries duty in uh in his yard
for him I couldn't play with him and he
was a tough kid like beat the crap out
of you uh no he would [ __ ] in his yard
and I had to bury it
you know and I didn't you know I didn't
I did it man I just did it man I [ __ ]
did it dude this mother was a librarian
I thought she was a nice lady and he
died actually drove a bass boat into an
embankment in the middle of the night
damned if we can look that up Mary
Orofino
and our IP as well man our IP what
summer I want to know some good tales
man we got we have some great video
questions that came in for you that
we'll get to in a minute uh yeah I'm
wondering I want to know what tale from
the manager functor right there is right
there six-day search man damn sure Funko
well the city is at what town is this in
that's uh Covington Lousiana inch a
functor how it got its name it's a
famous Indian River a big Indian threw a
big rock in there and that's a sound it
may be the winning that sounds about
right
it is yeah yeah that's crazy isn't it by
the overpass man I knew a [ __ ] kid
who jumped off that overpass one time
and [ __ ] hit a boat when he woke it
is that where you're originally from
yeah yeah man well then you know this is
all prayed and we just knew God was
gonna let his body surface so we could
take him out and give him a proper
burial and we and get proper closure man
Mary Oh Rafi no traveling upstream at
high speed just after midnight that'll
do it man what's he doing driving a boat
in the dark smashed into the overpass
had he been drinking I bet he had it
says Rafina was last seen at a bar right
there hmm
may have had a beer or two that's what
they put in there but man I'll tell you
that boy lived at top speed from the
moment I ever [ __ ] met him bruh it
was like it was like the whole world was
that I mean he was just at high speed
that kid you know if you were to ask him
right now he probably ain't got no
complaints then oh man he that guy yeah
yeah he didn't I mean I guess I was he
didn't believe in plumbing I [ __ ]
remember that outside you know I got
this oh we're gonna save a lot of money
mom and dad
kid berry oh that's right lovin what's
some wild stories that happen out there
man oh man wild like or tell me
something I was crazy you know I got
them all chicks trying to have sex to
pay off their bill is that true oh yeah
that happens I know I never did because
you're a handsome guy I'm sure you going
there and there's the opportunity for
sex every now and then it's happened
manok I had a lady in Seattle she was
she's good-looking she you know she it
took forever for her to come to the door
I still remember it because she was
trying so hard yeah I mean right you can
tell when somebody's coming on to you
yeah you know I'm blind and all but yeah
I mean I'm a dude yeah we missed most of
those signs all the time a lot of times
you miss him but so if you don't miss
him if a regular two doesn't miss and
rush really becoming strong that's what
I've realized with this chick answered
the door in a very thin white t-shirt
okay and that's it Wow and that t-shirt
was just long enough oh yeah right and
then her stuff was upstairs so I'll show
you you know follow me
so I followed her up the stairs staring
at her ass the whole way up hmm so I
could plunge her toilet in 30 seconds
and fix it and then she has me sit there
for like 20 minutes I bet mmm while she
sings karaoke to me on her little
private karaoke machine no way still in
this little t-shirt oh yeah with great
big titties they that you can see every
bit of there she didn't even need to be
wearing the t-shirt boat that at it you
could see him oh yeah I mean the shirt
is so thin you can see right there oh
but the point was I knocked on the door
and I got there and I got no answer and
I knocked again and knocked again it it
took her like five minutes to come to
the door and were you getting scared
what do you think she was doing I was
thinking she wasn't there I heard her at
first when she first came up I heard her
come to the door she looked through the
peephole mm-hmm she saw was an old fat
dude probably you know cuz you don't
know what plumbers showing up to your
house that's true huh so and then it was
I kept knocking I'm like so I called
dispatch because at the time it was this
road oh you were gonna Road yeah in at
the time this was before cell phone so
all we had was next aisle oh yeah beep
yeah you know I hey can you call this
customer that I'm here at her house and
I've knocked I
here that she's in there she ain't
answering oh yeah so they call him okay
she's coming to the door I'm not cool
thank you and she answers the door like
them no I know what the [ __ ] she was
doing she wouldn't God already and put
her makeup on and whatever else and was
she wearing sunglasses or anything nope
no she's slightly a little bit on the
heavyset side but you know good looking
and it's afternoon is it morning it was
morning probably ten eleven o'clock in
the morning you know here's what
anybody's body's like in the morning you
know right South African white chick
so that'll kind of get an accent oh yeah
it you know but still you know I'm on
the job right your profession are you
wearing a uniform oh yeah yeah and at
the time I was single and still you
don't [ __ ] where you eat no matter what
no you just it's only gonna be clean
[ __ ] or you don't [ __ ] where you clean
[ __ ] cuz that's that's true too but I I
don't know something got instilled in me
years ago don't ever have anything to do
with anything with work like that right
you know what I mean yeah don't [ __ ]
your clients it's gonna yeah yeah and
it's still a bad thing man once you put
sex into any work equation it all
becomes uncomfortable I me and Nick is
that why you guys don't get along that's
probably good a separate room no we've
never done anything like that man and we
never will Nick and that's why it's
working so well yeah look I promise you
the second me in here have any sexual
attraction it's over yeah so I moved to
Washington note so the lady are there
you're in the place oh that was it yeah
I hate that you know it's such a it
could have been so we I marry okey music
that's what I mean what karaoke music oh
she's singing like love songs and stuff
and trying to like sell me her voice
basically and you know why was she
saying that she used to do music she
considered and she was totally into
music and and she wanted me to hear her
sing she was trying to get me to nail
her on the couch right there Wow
where was the karaoke machine this was
after unstop in the toilet I had gone
back downstairs to write the invoice I'm
sitting on the couch she's next to me on
the couch yeah I got I've given her the
invoice she's got the checkbook and
instead of writing
the check so I can go to my next job she
spends all this time singing and trying
to seduce me basically and I'm trying to
be nice and trying to be cordial I'm not
trying and we'll look lady though what
song I care you have 20 years man
there's literally 20 years ago I bet 15
years ago I just can't remember was it
rap music no no I want to say it was
like slow like yeah so something you
know something softer than that oh wow
yeah sexual healing Marvin Gaye I think
you got she she was she was pulling out
all the stops to try it I had another
lady in the same town grab my junk I'll
come in and grab me and kiss me and I
had it literally I was married at that
time so I you know he said hey well even
if I wasn't right get off me pay me my
money let me go right let me go
mostly I'd be so scared you know
we're in an age of lawsuits yeah now we
definitely are though but 15 years ago
people I think we still were and what if
it don't work out say this girl kisses
me and I throw her on the floor and just
Ravager and we have a great time yeah
and then I don't call her back and now
she calls my company and says he raped
me on the floor or whatever no don't
even go down that road totally I'm so
rich so yeah I mean in hindsight do you
ever fantasize about having Evan had a
romantic instance though about you know
obviously the the South African one kind
of stands out if if I could have gone
back now being single I you know I
probably could have taken a run at that
and had a good time and all would have
been fine but a mate yeah I don't think
they say that [ __ ]
what uh what's one of the wildest year
we got to ask like how much [ __ ] is out
there really and how much [ __ ] is is all
is the middle of the earth just filling
up with [ __ ] all the time like I say it
all gets processed cleaned and then jump
back into the ocean and but the septic
box that thing that the septic box is
even more
environmentally friendly Wow a better
for everything it it contains it
decomposes it leeches clean water out
into your yard and that's why you see
those green lines and a lot of people's
grass because that's where the septic
tank leach field is okay and it makes
the grass a little bit greener in those
areas Oh interesting yeah but and does
it sift the sludge or just a sludge
builds up because really in the end it's
very little solids right right
a perfectly working septic tank if it is
working it has active live bacteria in
it constantly breaking down the solid
material okay separating the solids from
liquids they sell this product called
riddex but you can use buttermilk you
can use cultured cultured butter or
cultured yeast I mean all these things
work to promote the bacterial growth of
your septic tank Oh interesting bleach
and other chemicals tend to kill the
active bacteria they're doing the job so
you don't want that so you want those
cultures you want to create yeah you
want to have like a little ecosystem in
the job my grandma and grandpa were I
mean they had people coming over to
their house but they lived in the same
house for like 25 years and when the guy
came because the law says when you sell
a house that you have to have a septic
tank pumped no matter what oh wow so
that's when you start over yeah so when
the guy came to pump their septic tank
after it had been buried for 25 years he
said it looks like brand-new Wow this
didn't need to be done this tank is
working properly and if they are working
properly do you know a true working
septic tank will never have to be pumped
dang that's amazing yeah yeah it's it's
a completely self-contained system if
you do the right things - yeah you know
you can't just ignore it and let it
build up you got to treat it you got to
take care of you can't put the wrong
things in it now have you ever had to go
looking for something that someone
flushed that they need it back like a
tooth or like a wedding ring $20,000
diamond ring really at midnight
yeah and when they on drugs or something
no no no as a lady at an apartment comes
the manager of an apartment complex his
years ago this is in Alabama the boss
calls me and says hey man this this lady
and we know there's a buddy is one of
our clients you know they got 1500
apartments in there we're going there
all
time hey she dropped her wedding ring
down the toilet at the office can you go
get it so I get there and she's just
bawling crying see you hug her what do
you do just go and you love no yeah I'm
a plumber man nobody touch me area yeah
and I got a rotor probably got turned
somewhere on me so I go in the bathroom
and I take the toilet off the floor and
I give it a shake hmm and I can hear
it's in there oh that's good news man
because if it makes it down the pipe I
gotta send the camera down there and I
gotta basically really slowly with the
camera until I find it and then I gonna
chase something down like a snake with a
hook on it try and get it out and how
that's like an endoscopy almost how much
does that cost
how much is that up charge with you when
you get that cam out um it varies by
area obviously in this area I think a
camera is around $500 yeah okay so back
in the day this was like I say from 15
years ago I want to say we would
probably charge her around $200 to do
that
fortunately I found it in the toilet so
so I didn't have to go that route I had
the camera in the truck but no need
busting it out nice so I go to shake it
I'm like it's in there so you shake the
tool you can hear the pipe you can hear
a rattle I can hear that the rattling
around the inside so I say way to think
about it stead of just look listen first
it fell out I got it put it on my finger
on my pinky finger put the toilet back
together and I go back into the office
cuz it's midnight she's still waiting
for me I'm like I couldn't find it oh no
no no I'm kidding here it is here it is
yeah
did you get down on one knee no oh man
here you go she gave me a hundred over
tip oh it's nice yeah for it cuz it was
an overtime like midnight thing hmm I
think the bill was probably like 85
bucks 15 years ago in Alabama ya hear
that same midnight charge would probably
be wondering yeah four or five hundred
Wow from from a commercial company for
me to come and do it I don't care about
overtime or late night or whatever it's
all same
is there anything you notice about
people like just in different areas
going into different areas over time
like do you notice any difference in
like people in different environments or
anything like that man yeah California
is tough yeah it it's
I hate using the word liberal because
I'm early like that word but it was very
liberal out here yeah it's it's very
people out here at pussy's oh yeah yeah
I mean I don't know how else to say it
there's a lot of lab eeeh freelance the
vaginal California has taken place soft
so soft man it's and that's what it
makes it tough being here too but then
there's also beautiful side talking to
because you know um the weather's so
nice there's so many great people that
come here to chase their dreams to do
things like there's there's so many
types of people like it's tough but yeah
it gets this should get you soft out
it's tough but it's also the best you
know it's it's the best it's the best
and the worst you got to take the bad
with the good yeah there's there's that
soft side of a lot of people but also
there's there's there's tons of good
people yeah if you hook up and you meet
with the right ones then you can kind of
get set here so yeah you know the
holiday rush is upon us
and if you sell stuff online then you
better get ready and you better get
ready with shipstation
with more people buying online than ever
before in the history of time you need
to be able to get orders out quickly
efficiently and affordably but how do
you keep track of all of those orders
and get them out in time well that is
ship station with just a few clicks
you'll be managing orders printing
labels and getting those products out
the door and delivered in time for the
holidays that's right you can still get
them delivered in time for the holidays
no matter where you're selling Amazon
Etsy or your own website shipstation
brings all your orders into one simple
interface quick go into this and then go
into paypal and print and off the edge
that takes forever ship station will
handle it with
all of the major carriers including USPS
FedEx and UPS ship station lets you
compare and choose the best shipping
solution for you and your customer
no wonder ship station is the number one
choice for online sellers and you can
use our offer code
théo to get a 60 day free trial that's
two months of free no hassle stress free
shipping
just visit ship station dot-com click on
the microphone at the top of the page
and type in Theo
that's ship station comm enter offer
code theo ship station make ship happen
oh sorry just shaving my junk trying to
get that little Christmas tree above my
wing cuz it's holiday time that's right
I'm trying to shave a little bit of a
plant right up above my shawl song you
know a little bit of gristle toe that's
manscaped is what I'm using guys I'm
manscaping and support for this past
weekend comes from manscaped the number
one company in men's below-the-belt
grooming you can jingle balls to the
walls fellas listen up untrimmed pubes
are a thing of the past something you
might find in a horse and buggy or a
mercantile it's time to gear up and get
yourself the gift of Shaving this
holiday season I'm talking about the
manscaped perfect package 2.0 everyone
has accidentally nicked their balls or
something like that but you don't want
Santa to cut a hole in this sack do you
neither do you that's why the
revolutionary company manscaped has
redesigned the electric trimmer their
lawn mower 2.0 has proprietary advanced
skin-safe technology so this trimmer
won't Knick your bag or snag your nuts
it's also waterproof you can use it in
the
shalwar the perfect package also comes
with a manscape boxer-briefs
pair that'll keep your junk feeling
fresh all day
tighten your junk up and put it in that
fresh sack tis the season to get the
manscaped perfect package 2.0 for
yourself your dad or your brother get
20% off and free shipping with the code
theo at manscaped comm that's right get
th EO at manscape comm that's 20% off
and free shipping and use code theo
clean up your nuts and make Santa proud
this year when I was young the plumbers
came because my mom had been flushing
coffee grounds on the garbage disposal
and the and the little paper thing that
was in the coffee pot I don't know she
even liked putting that in there just in
the morning because it was easy she was
on the go and she was like do not tell
the plumbers that I've been doing that
or the we're gonna have to pay and the
building won't have to pay right and
right when the fire escape there's like
I was such a rat I was like put my
fleshy coffee grounds and the paper
things they would have they would have
found it anyway I never even told
anybody until just now man but I feel so
bad if I get through it you have to pay
I don't think she did man I think the
plumbers knew that like she was a single
mom and stuff more like I will you know
I've done that before actually where you
know so you go to an apartment complex
so you go to a rental and you know a lot
of rentals out go to where the owner
would say hey if the customer put
something in there that they weren't
supposed to I ain't paying right like
tampons or you know paper towels it was
a big one we get a lot of paper towels
out of drains baby wipes oh yeah baby
wife seemed impossible to flush they
don't break down yeah so if they get
down there and they get caught on
something they're just gonna pack up and
other stuff is gonna pack up on it
here's a couple of good tips you know
for years they would say coffee grounds
is okay and the garbage disposal
eggshells is supposed to be good for it
No
don't ever put pasta don't ever put rice
don't do eggshells don't do coffee
grounds those are not good for your
garbage disposal they go in the trash or
in the compost your garbage disposal is
for the tiniest little bits or
whatever's left on your plate is what
your garbage disposal was originally
designed to do chunk that stuff up mix
it with some water and send it down what
about fat like if you're cutting the fat
off of a chicken like you're getting
some Pete chicken pieces I mean if you
guys want to that I'll get it in there
but don't don't take done don't don't
carve a whole chicken and throw all the
extra stuff in your garbage disposal
that's not gonna be good for it you're
gonna call a plumber
what about bones no okay no bones no one
lady one lady called me because she
stopped up her garbage disposal with a
whole steak she called him his cute her
son was gonna come over for dinner he
called he said he couldn't make it she
got pissed off and she threw the steak
down the garbage disposal it didn't make
it oh and she hadn't cooked it no I was
wrong so yeah that's dead that uncooked
meat won't go down really huh no well no
I mean it'll chunk up but once it gets
through there it's just gonna pack up
Rekha's it's that weird consistency at
that point so garbage disposals come in
different power you know someone really
strong I went to this frat house in
Auburn Alabama tons of frat dudes and
they needed a new garbage supposed to
their old one and taking a crap or
whatever War Eagle more Eagles war damn
Eagle
so I get him this one horsepower garbage
disposal when I put it in in the head of
the frat houses there and he's like is
this a good garbage disposal is it
strong and I'm like they actually
advertised this garbage disposal will
chew up a beer bottle damn
and he's like word he's like that's
awesome like okay cool bye give me my
money and I left like a week later I had
to go back to that same fraternity house
because all the pipes underneath the
garbage disposal and the whole main pipe
underneath the house was packed full of
broken glass
because they had a party that weekend
and dudes were going watched this and
just dropping beer bottle after beer
bottle down the sink
have you ever uh have you ever seen a
gas-powered garbage disposal no that'd
be pretty cool though it'll be pretty
cool huh I think that thing would work I
wouldn't want to connect it to my to my
sewer system no cuz that's just gonna
send too much nastiness down there you
know now if you run out of drain what's
up can you pour gasoline down your drain
don't port Drano down your drain really
no man that stuff's bad is it I guess
honestly do tonneaus but I'm not even
feeling good about myself as a person
I'll go get a couple things in ray now
and pour it in all the drains in my
place why I think it just makes me feel
like something's being done even though
I'm not feeling good do you own the
house no it's an event [ __ ] hey your
pipes yeah but I just like I don't know
something about it's like oh man I can't
unclog my own life but I'm gonna do my
best on these drains right now you know
I think it's kind of a anyway it's
anything with hydrochloric or sulfuric
acid pipes are not designed to handle
that Wow it might eat through the clog
but whether it does or not there's gonna
be some residual acid left in your pipes
I have grabbed pipes solid cast-iron
pipes that people had used Drano on and
I can crush them with my hand oh because
they're so brittle or plastic pipes that
just have the whole bottom channel where
the water runs oh yeah gone just melt it
away yeah that's what we had grown up
Abbi plastic piping right through some
plywood like right boot through a hole
in piece of plywood or so you you think
getting a drain is unstopped or you
think getting a drain unstopped is
expensive try replacing a pipe yeah
that's really gets pricey right so you
you want to spend $20.00 on some Drano
to try and save yourself a hundred or
two hundred dollars on a plumber for
stopping your drain that drain will
might cost you thousands in the pipe
repair that that comes down the road or
the damage that the water leak will
cause because you're not gonna notice it
right away it's gonna do some wood
damage first and some mold and rot [ __ ]
that's crazy well I can't even yeah cuz
I I guess I'll stop getting it and some
of them I get the expensive when the
little Goldbach
there's better tricks boiling water
works really well gilli yeah boiling
water with a little bit of vinegar in it
and keeps your drain smelling good and
it keeps him running clean dude what's
crazy is in the morning when I get up I
get some warm water and put some vinegar
in it there you go
see we're you you're already right here
myself oh and drink Haley yeah like it's
like a popular thing we looked at Abdul
Monday how does that work it works good
I feel like it makes me feel they make
me feel like kind of I don't want to say
fresh Brooke that's kind of a [ __ ]
words but it makes me feel kind of like
so you're masculine from this side yeah
masculine from the top all right that's
a [ __ ] Manson Gill what's coming up a
lot is apple cider vinegar yeah yeah
that's why I use all right yeah sorry
not straight up like dye your hair of it
oh my girl was doing that for a little
while yeah you know like that in
something else
she said it ate it didn't taste very
good but it was supposed to be pretty
good for like does not help good yeah
yeah it does not taste good I just read
on there though that it relieves
nighttime leg cramps which is because it
has a warm potassium and honey damn I
[ __ ] want some right now dude because
I got on these uh compression socks
because my legs hurt what is the most
complicated septic system that exists
out there or the most complicated one
that you've ever come upon hmm they
don't they are not complicated they're
not no it's it's hard to find one like
that they're they're usually that the
most complicated thing I run into is
when people try and they don't know what
they're doing that day before yesterday
for example I went to a house where the
guy called me and said this is gonna be
a big thing but do what you can and I go
in there and the plumber couldn't he
wasn't a plumber the guy couldn't put
the toilet pipe in the center of the
space right where the toilet goes so he
didn't and he installed it over in the
corner and he put the toilet on it like
a diagonal
coming out funny and it didn't sit right
it didn't look right
it was not proper not only that but he
didn't use the right material so the
toilet wasn't even stuck to the floor it
was just kind of oh ya been on a
functional yeah I know it feels risky
yeah and soon as I start moving things
and I get in there I'm like had this not
have taken place in the first place it
would have been so much easier for me to
fix but that I have to undo the problems
of somebody else right and then recreate
from you know basically I got to undo
all this before I can go back to the
beginning so when it gets complicated is
when somebody tackles a project they
probably shouldn't have yeah should have
just call the plumber in the first place
right so yeah instead if you get brave
ideas to just kind of Lewis and Clark
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] future change it up
and hire somebody that knows what
they're doing yeah it's worth the money
I mean it's some of these companies you
know I can't be everywhere so you're not
gonna get me man some of these companies
are not very cheap but it is worth the
money these guys have learned a lot over
there however many years it took to be a
professional plumber which your company
Bret it's called toilet champion oh
really
yeah hell it's crazy because in my mind
I'm like this guy is a toilet chain yeah
I want a contest you did yeah I was
putting a toilet together it was a it
was a plumbing supply store in
Washington was having this contest they
had all shitload ha ha
[ __ ] loads of toilets in the box like
everything is in the box that you need
to put this toilet together oh wow and
the contest and a barbecue and
everything and they had like fenders
there that were selling tools and stuff
like that and this was the contest
whoever puts a toilet together in the
fastest amount of time you get a like a
trophy you got a hundred bucks and there
was something else involved in it and I
did it in a minute 50 for him out of the
box fully assembled no leaks so I get
this little trophy with a dude holding a
toilet up over a head I'm like I'm the
toilet champion that's been the name of
my business ever since that's beautiful
and toilet champion is based where it's
here and
Angeles yeah hi Pacific area Los Angeles
sir
I tend not to come into LA too much I
kind of stick more toward the valley and
Thousand Oaks see me look I mean I'll
move around where you know dude I went
to Cambria a couple of weeks ago and
repipe the whole house that's four hours
away so so you'll do some adventures
you'll do some stuff um let's see the
toilet champion Riley champion calm man
it's its own website I love it we got a
question right here from a guy who has a
beard now can you cut your hair and
flush it down the pipe yeah you can't
yeah oh yeah that's all right
don't do it like large quantities at
once but I mean little bits it'll go
through it'll go through fine have you
ever found something a pipe that you
thought this person could be a murderer
doing something dangerous like some bone
and journey like that I found a baby in
a pipe once they you didn't I don't know
what a baby human oh damn
yeah that was pretty sad day I had to
call the police
you did yeah so she she miscarried he
beat the crap out of her oh she
miscarried flushed it so it wasn't a
very large it was just barely bigger
than the size your hand or so but uh
that fortunately for her their sewer
line was already stopped up so when she
flushed it down it didn't go all the way
and a couple of days later they had
called roto-rooter and when I got there
and undid the cap out in the front yard
the baby came out oh and I'm looking I
had to look at it for a couple of
minutes because I've seen so many rats
in pipes right so a rat that has been
drowned or is it will lose all its fur
and it'll also be white and very small
and have bones so you got to kind of
look it over it was not dissimilar from
that minus the tail and all that but it
was definitely a human baby Wow
and like so what do you do did you feel
something like spiritually at that point
at all yeah I felt horrible I didn't
know what was really going on at the
time I think I was like 21 or 22 you
know I was very young so I I picked up
the nextel and I called my boss hey
Lamar man it baby came floating out of
his drain what do I do
I'm way on the country on the middle of
nowhere you know and he goes you pack up
your [ __ ] get in the
I can leave right now don't unstop that
drain don't do nothing so I did I packed
up my I didn't even talk to the lady I
just loaded up my stuff and drove away
they called the police the police showed
up they did their thing the guy went to
jail for beating the crap out of the
lady ah so at least that happened so
right sad story and all that but also
justice yeah maybe yeah maybe they don't
find out right and maybe he continues
beating the crap out of her
so you know it's funny it's almost like
a little bit of euphemism for life it's
like you think you can put everything
into the hide every year inside of
yourself or in the you know in the
drains you know you know emotional
drains are in the ground or wherever but
it all comes to the surface eventually
eventually it's all gonna pop out you
can't hide it forever yeah yeah r.i.p
man it's o sayyaa dude what kind of bait
was it a boy or girl do you know I I
couldn't tell it was like I say
associate and it had been in there for a
while so it was already starting to
kinda and it wasn't fully developed in
the last night yeah yes I have been a
dream baby and it was Alabama that was
know about you hmm
I found an alarm clock in the toilet I
found it Elmo
say that you're late for work you're not
late for work that was exactly it the
alarm clock went off dude threw it that
way and it went right down the toilet
[Laughter]
this past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare there's someone that you love
that's struggling with inability or not
inability but he'll they don't have a
skill well we got a guy on here today
that has a skill he's a plumber and look
at how well he's doing Skillshare is a
supporter of this past weekend it's an
online learning community for creators
creators with more than 25,000 classes
and design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity career and creativity take
classes in social media mobile
photography marketing even illustration
are you a freelancer well you can be
just get a skill try book keeping for
freelancers how to handle your finance
one of our most popular courses one of
their most popular join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for tpw
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering this past weekend listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes that's everything just go
to Skillshare comm slash Theo von that's
right go to Skillshare comm slash Theo
von to start your two months now man I
just I keep forgetting to send one of
these to my friend who just had a new
baby boy I got a mail out a Ridge wallet
to him so he can save money because he's
gonna need it taking care of that little
one that's right the ridge wallet helps
you carry what you need every day it'll
streamline how you carry cash and cards
in their flagship wallet instead of
carrying that big lump a dunk in your
back looking like you got bad plumbing
in your pants now you can get that front
pocket carry and also this thing is made
out of titanium specialty metals we're
talking military-grade like carbon fiber
it's proven to be bulletproof waterproof
and chainsaw proof though I never
recommend you take a chainsaw to your
money the ridge is so confident you'll
enjoy their product they've made it as
simple as possible and free shipping so
you can get it fast free returns in case
you don't like it you don't like it you
don't keep it and if you do like it
there's a lifetime guarantee there's
over 30,000 five-star reviews so they've
got a lot to be confident about see
exactly how it works by going to ridge
comm Theo
that's ridge comm slash th EO and use
code Theo for 10% off and Cory Huff I
promise I'll be sending you you yours
soon brother I'm so sorry I know that uh
that you've had that little baby for a
while
now the link isn't in the description
that's ridge comm slash Theo for that
front pocket carry let's go to this
video question that came in right here
what up hips I was wondering if it's
true they called the day after
Thanksgiving around Friday in the
plumbing world they really did why no
gang gang gang brah they do busiest
plumbing day of the year for service
plumbers and that's just based on sheer
volume of fee see I mean it's just
called Brown Friday it's to be honest
it's mostly kitchen sinks yeah
potato peels 80% of it's gonna be potato
peels in the garbage disposal hmm
they you know you got a big Thanksgiving
dinner you just peel 20 potatoes they
all went down the drain they didn't go
very far right yeah so yeah yeah potato
peels that have this have that same
consistency layers and they can gather
up yep so they call it he's right though
they do call it brown Friday man I do
one year I did fourteen service calls in
one day the day after Thanksgiving and
is it mostly [ __ ] related or is it like
a mix of things it's you said a lot of
its food like I say all right out of
those 14 service calls I think 12 of
them were kitchen sinks so it's just
food particles and everything and the
other two are main lines do you go to
places where sometimes people are
embarrassed like they like come in but
they'll never even look you in the eyes
it's over there oh yeah well not only
that people have a lot of shame around
theses in around [ __ ] I so it went
beyond that because several years after
quitting with roto-rooter I started
working for one of the largest luxury
hotels in the world
Wow I don't know if I'm allowed to say
who it is oh you're certainly allowed oh
we have four seasons four seasons in
Seattle I'm working for four seasons in
Seattle and and those toilets stop up
just like any other toilet but these
people are fancy and they don't want to
interact with the common folk who is
coming to unstop their toilet
yeah the plumber is a strange guy well I
actually were coming for the four
seasons oh so yeah I was missing one or
four like kind of a
eventually I worked for three okay but
one at a time I work for seasoned
Seattle for three years as their
overnight maintenance so it wasn't just
plumbing I was doing drywall repair and
painting and all this other you know
whatever needed to be done including you
know all the building maintenance and
handling guestroom calls so yeah most of
the time if a guest were to call with a
stopped-up toilet that guests would not
be in the room they just dip out let you
fix it they don't want it yeah you know
you're already got to smell their [ __ ]
they don't want to talk to you yeah for
the most part there was some small
occasions where they would be in there
and they would just be it it's in there
right yeah lady I know where the
bathroom is I I work here have you ever
had anybody like put on a mask or
something so they don't see like so much
shame surrounding like body you know
activity and stuff they do but no I I
had one lady who nobody hiding behind
their hand or any like anything it's no
no I I had one lady open the door with
the robe and the robe was open I mean
just everything was showing am
nice-looking or not yeah real nice
looking yeah I'm trying to lose my job
right uh I can't come in I'm sorry like
no no no it's okay come on in and I'm
like no I can't her husband pops around
from the corner and he's like yeah it's
okay come on in
I'm like no it's not okay yeah like you
surprise me with the man I think I'll
try to invite me in here for some freaky
stuff honey down let me fix your toilet
have you ever had anybody offer you yeah
just straight up point-blank here's a
couple hundred dollars watching me bone
Rhonda or whatever you know like watch
us do something man I might get down on
that but no I never had that that I I
mean if I just gotta stand there and
watch yeah yeah it'll come man I'll tell
you this man when you guys are the
toilet champion you throw in $300 he'll
watch you guys bounties somebody will
hurt you now to come to it hey hey man
money is money you don't pay me $300
look I gotta do no hard work I just
gotta stand there and watch Frank it's
still plumbing you're watching right
somebody's laying pipe get that half a
sandwich dog here comes a white guy with
a question Oh from Seattle from your old
stomping yeah you got a nice hat on and
I will say before I play this one we got
more questions for you than we have in a
lot
time for a guess but like two-thirds of
them were have you ever had sex on a job
did anybody ask you to clean your pipes
a lot of that stuff type stuff yeah a
lot of euphemisms oh yeah we covered
that pretty in-depth what's happening
Theo Ryan from Ohio when asked Super
Mario there he was cleaning out toilets
clean up real nasty drain he glove up
the hands or is he going raw he used to
work with this cat in Pittsburgh he's
from Pittsburgh just thought I'd throw
that in there from Pittsburgh he you
know we worked on the river together on
the boats and any time he was cleaning
the shower clean the toilet
he never gloved up the hands I always
called him nasty he said it was cuz he
used to be a plumber and you know all
plumbers did that I just wanted to know
if Super Mario there did that and he'll
probably try to lie to you say he didn't
cuz you got him on the spot right now so
just don't shake his hand when he goes
to leave Gang Gang Gang Gang brother
Thank You Ryan was that Ryan from Ohio
yep Ryan Boyer Oh
Thank You mr. Boyer I appreciate that's
a good question it is yeah
first four or five years no gloves yeah
that's my toilet champion and and still
if I don't have gloves I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah I mean if I have them I'll use
them but if not I know how to wash my
hands yeah I'm not trying to stick my
hands in my face or on my eyes or shake
hands with people or anything yeah at
work here's the other thing I went to
cooking school for a year so that was
every day four hours a day thing and and
the biggest thing that that they teach
you in cooking schools to wash your
hands and and such good cleanliness
habits with your hands so I can
understand the difference you know you
know what I'm saying that it's okay to
stick your hands in poop you know you're
gonna wash your hands before you shake
somebody else's hand all right you know
stick it in your mouth or whatever but
yeah no worries I don't care yeah you
got good hand
etiquette yeah you got hand plans you
play plans for you trying to touch food
right after cleaning out somebody's
toilet yeah I probably wash my hands
three or four times before I do that
yeah you ain't gonna clean out of
[ __ ] and then [ __ ] polish off a
thing of deviled eggs immediately
most likely not yeah but back in the day
I did a mean in the first five years
yeah I'd go on stop somebody's thing and
then go eat lunch without washing my
hands hell yeah I didn't know any better
I was a kid so yeah and at that time do
you when you're it's it's water when
you're young you can spare a couple
years you're like oh I get lymphoma I
get you know carcinogen or whatever I'll
be fine you know saying I [ __ ] lose a
limb I sprouted another you have your
head invincibility after yeah like
whatever dude I'll [ __ ] have aw you
know I have a couple spare ribs a buck
and a half a turd for lunch bro I gotta
be careful when I get out of bed because
it's a ways down you know what do we
have Nick let's get to a video question
I'm not we actually had a that was a
great question that by that guy yeah
yeah I I would have just assumed yes
they do wear gloves so that's very
interesting
we actually had a message from someone
you might know oh it's a it's a voice
memo actually not a video so let's hear
this what's the biggest turd you've ever
seen while plumbing mmm that's my father
really yeah I know that guy's wow that's
like Luke I am your father
how does like Star Wars II and she will
yeah one more time with you what's the
biggest turd you've ever seen while
plumbing oh that's awesome man
yeah I you know it has to be the one I
was talking about earlier the lady with
the baseball poops
yeah there's : Ryan that's what they
call it's great that's great
it just came in about our own I'm gonna
have to get ahold of my friend and
Alabama and tell him that he'll laugh
he'll remember I have a Houston Jersey
cola drive through this thigh Young
Award winner now I I mean yeah that was
the biggest one while plumbing but I was
walking down the streets
like I don't know 10 years ago I was
plumbing a building actually and we were
just taking it because we were
commercial plumbers doing high-rise
buildings and kind of got out of that
turd chasing business
that's what they call roto-rooter man
Church a stasis yeah so I got into the
new construction high-rise clean pipe no
no more dirty hands right and we were
walking downtown Seattle headed to Whole
Foods like we did every day to have our
10 o'clock morning 15-minute break and
we passed I kid you not a one-foot turd
oh wow I mean in diameter it was a pile
of poop [ __ ] Squatch now that's a sling
in diameter Jesus and where'd they get
it from you think you think it came
directly out of a body think it was a
group of people so human Terrence I'm
human turn and it was just kind of like
one of these kinda soft-serve deal yeah
that's a thing though that's that's a
homeless thing I don't know if you knew
that or not homeless in major cities
[ __ ] on the sidewalks on purpose oh yeah
yeah I knew that it's like there [ __ ]
you to society or whatever yeah so it's
not uncommon to see a big turd and it's
I almost think like they're kicking back
like hey I got a three-day turd built up
I gotta go find a sidewalk you know yeah
and then we'll kick back and watch all
these people walk past it Oh honestly
you can't [ __ ] find entertainment now
come on man that's that's free
entertainment it's amazing imagine
laying just a real snake in the basket
heater across the way and then you your
buddy crack open a couple Mattie light
and sit over in the corner and [ __ ]
watch I saw that in Hollywood like two
months ago oh and people had stepped in
it so there was like foot tracks
oh and away from it it was crazy you
know it's interesting too because at a
certain point with bodily functions we
become almost like animals in a way you
know it's like we mark our territory or
oh yeah and when I was young I used to
be real scared and now you're an aide in
places in my bedroom all right you know
and I think in hindsight I never really
knew why I did it but I think I was like
scared that something was gonna come get
me you know I would mark my territory
you know I don't think it was a choice
that I was making I felt like it was a
not involuntary reaction but just
something that was more on the
animalistic DNA of me you know
did you ever outgrow that yes I did well
I have not yet you really Wow
you'll just do it sometimes I get in
trouble with my girl and my fiancee a
lot for peeing in inappropriate areas
wow that's interesting do you think
there's any reason why you got into
plumbing no no uh-uh
but I'm drinking sometimes only comes
into play with the with the peeing on
the floor or whatever oh yeah on an
ironing board in a hotel room or
something or ya never know yeah I mean
so you'll do some wild pissin but also
more to your point like you're saying
kind of every time I move into a new
place and I gotta pee on it yeah in some
somewhere yeah I'm gonna be okay I don't
know why I just have to do my buddy's
dad when I was growing up we used to get
on the roof and how many been drinking
and he let us watch him piss down the
chimney down the chimney come inside and
then mommy wouldn't know we'd sneak up
and then the mom would [ __ ] gets oh
yeah yes they just get that they just
can't understand why you can't go use
the toilet yeah well as I don't have to
do you you could be you're supposed to
be in the toilet but you can also pee
wherever you want exactly
wherever you want in a suitcase on
ironing board what do you feel like it's
territorial for you I think so yeah yeah
yeah I hope I don't know if I'll grow
out of it I didn't I don't care if I do
or not really it's yeah it's not really
a the only bad vibe I get from this is
from from the messy on see yeah she's
not comfortable with it well look dude
that's when you break out that trophy
and say hey late I am the toilet
champion it's a little champion I do
with the toilet yeah it is gonna did I
need to get a belt you really do man
I'm not joking bro I probably could give
one of the kids when you go into the
house and they're in there um that's
awesome that your dad called in because
we didn't know that he was gonna call in
right now right I just recognized the
last name yeah s Cosby was on the lineup
of just people that had called yeah
that's pretty awesome yeah that's cool
did you and your father ever work
together
no he well yes and no not not really so
I'd have to say no I got a job working
at the same company as him but for a
very brief period of time we weren't
doing the same thing we weren't even
working in the same area but it was only
an in-between until I could construction
plumbers get laid off from time to time
you know you hit a big job or whatever a
high-rise building when that building is
over a lot of those plumbers are gonna
go on unemployment I see it that seems
to be the way of it and I don't like to
sit still yeah so my mom Ann had a
company he was working for and they'll
hire anybody no it's barely better than
minimum wage but it you know his money
Wow so I wouldn't work for him for like
a couple of months but like I said him
and I never really he him and I do
different things he's a painter and you
guys must be pretty close up he called
in that's pretty cool oh yeah I mean um
since we've become adults yeah we're
best friends oh yeah you know he's my
best guy friend I think wow my fiance is
probably my best real friend and your
dad is a pretty hard worker himself oh
yeah yeah he's 62 63 been working his
whole life so that's cool instilled some
good values I would say yeah it sounds
like a man how do you get from so for
the young plumbers out there and
plumbers apprentices and you know young
man they're like what do I do do is
there a way up out through that business
how did you you know tell me how to get
that those young men can get from
starting working from a company with a
roto-rooter or a commercial group some
outfit like that how they can get to
that next level of being now a toilet
champion yeah you know or
self-sufficient or self-sufficient yeah
yeah because there's a lot of there's
pride in that
there's even though there's other
expenses that come in you know it's nice
to be able to to have something that
feels like yours you know to piss in
your own [ __ ] yard yeah you know hey
make no mistake I got to work hard
for and I'm always out there hustling
still yeah I mean I'm not hit a easy
street by any me know and there never
really is the more work you bring on or
create or that you're a part of the more
work there is yeah it's like it's like
growth begets growth and it's it's a
blessing and a curse there's a law of
diminishing returns it's like you know
it's never it's great but it's different
yeah yeah so to answer that I would say
to start and if you're in your own I
mean
pride I want to say pride in your own
abilities or your own work ethic you
know how hard I work and how I want it
to look is what drives people paying me
they pay me because what I put in looks
good and it works I don't charge a
fortune but I'm not the cheapest out
there either I pick what works
price-wise for me and I try to be as
completely open and fair with my
customers as I possibly can be and that
seems to work well whether you're doing
plumbing or carpentry or you know treat
treat people right treat them honestly
don't rob them and you'll get customers
for life yeah I've got people that call
me from five six some ten years ago hey
you still in Seattle I got some plumbing
oh no I'm sorry man you know but they
hold on to your number forever if you
did them right that's so true
you save it in there yeah right plumbing
if you're to ask how to succeed on your
by yourself treat people right and don't
rob them yeah and that'll be fine what
commercial plumbing companies are
charging it I understand the overhead
and the expenses and the insurance and
everything else and advertising and all
that but it's still you know the owner
is making money for doing very little
right you know it feels egregious it's a
little like it's a little too far so at
at some point you got out though you
started to do your own thing would you
do just you started it in LLC you
started to do I have an LLC right and
then you started advertising how did you
go about that I'm just trying to get
some of these young guys who may be
curious about that sort of stuff how to
get out of somebody else's totally yeah
and get into their own choice up their
own [ __ ] yeah at least for ten years
yeah a Craigslist was a good way to
start that's how I got my start
there's a couple other avenues like
Angie's List and there's a couple of
apps that you can use that will send you
work but you have to pay for it so
thumbtack Angie's List there's a couple
of others that will give you job leads
but if you were to accept those job
leads they can be quite expensive and
all they are is leads right so if the
customer decides not to go with your
price then you're out that money you're
still paying for that lead yeah and and
they and that bill started getting so
expensive that it wasn't worth it for
the return I was getting out of the jobs
that would hire me I say so it ended up
being you know some guy needs a new
water heater for example oh okay well
yeah I can put in a water heater way
cheaper than they can put in a water
heater but it cost me $100 just to tell
that guy that and what if I tell him and
he decides to go with somebody I'm still
out at $100 yeah so I gave up on all
those they are an option if you're
small-time really small-time and you're
only doing the minimum bids then it's
probably not going to be too expensive
but if you're out there and you're
trying to make it a business
Craigslist works pretty well because
it's five dollars per post and that's
not very expensive and you do you get
one job and you got your return on that
yep and word-of-mouth
I think is probably my best I mean that
it seems to work better than anything
and I've been here a few years I have
enough built-up now that I rarely do but
I do post every once in a while on
Craigslist matter of fact that's how
Johnny found me oh really
um yeah and Jionni everybody knows is uh
is the beautiful little twink and I'm
not sure he's a twink but he is a nice
young man who's on a new PC and actor
he's in he's gonna be on a new
television show called what is it
he was just in he was just in the sixth
season of power power yeah he was just
in the sixth season of power but he has
a new show that he's taping right now
that we can't talk about yeah but we
just did okay oh we don't know what it
is yeah but also we have insurance
banisky yeah if I'm paying for it
have you ever seen kids like I knew we'd
go to these kids house in some time they
would flush the toilet obviously and
then use it as like a little bit of like
a pool or something
one of the kids oh you see that a lot oh
yeah oh yeah yeah kids kids little
swimming whatever yeah yeah in the
toilet where we had this one kids small
Alan and he could [ __ ] literally bro
go all the way under the water and hold
his breath yeah in the toilet yeah
that's gross it was beautiful I thought
but yeah now in haunting as an adult if
I saw him in here I'd be like get the
[ __ ] out of there Alan let's see ya
overflow to upstairs tub on purpose yeah
the tub was that big toilet that's
that's a big one to see happen a lot or
bobbing for apples people ever do
anything like they've you ever seen any
crazy somebody a lot of tit to pee oh go
pee
is that okay yeah yeah yeah dude don't
pee in here I got to mark my territory
somewhere just mark it in the bathroom
across the hall there's a key right on
there Nick we'll get it for you today's
episode is brought to you by toilet
champion you get that [ __ ] oh baby oh
man all right we got a couple more
questions for you that have come in here
from listeners man and then we're gonna
we're gonna get you on your way man this
guy's just trying not to get a bit it's
a very specific question for him but hey
Theo man this is JD I'm out of Pittsburg
Kansas and I see you on you're getting
on with the plumber so I got a plumbing
question for you I turned my bathroom
sink on it just can't keep up the drain
is full I can't leave it running you
know ah
so I'd like to ask the plumber what what
should I do about that Gang Gang Gang
bra Thank You Bradley was that his name
it was
Jadey sorry JD Bradley I'm Bradley right
but still not so much thanks JD that's a
good question man that's a really good
question so yeah he's in there in the
morning he gets it going and then he's
like oh [ __ ] I'm trying to shave and
stuff now I got to wait and let it go
down what's going on there bread that's
happened to every like college house
I've ever been in and like almost
immediately and then you just live with
it
yeah man such a simple fix to really I
love this I love this question JD
five-minute fix he's back in business he
can either grab that stopper and pull it
straight out but sometimes they're
connected to a rod that's behind the
pipe he has to reach behind there and
undo that nut pull the rod out and then
he can pull the stopper out
and there'll be so much gunk and hair
and nastiness on the bottom side of that
stopper you throw that in the trash put
the stopper back in slide the rod back
in and tighten that little nut that
holds it in place go so what's going on
there is the problem is he if he pulls
the stopper up it won't come all the way
off right there the pipe is like this
right and there's a rod into the pipe
and the stopper is connected to that rod
that way you can't pull it out right so
and that little nut you just it's it's
finger tight usually ninety percent of
the time it's finger tight line and you
just undo it
pull that rod out to release that
stopper and pull it out clean it all off
a lot of times what I'll do is I'll
clean it all off and put the rod back in
without the stopper and then just drop
the stopper in so it's free-floating you
can you can use it as a stopper it still
works but if you want to take it out you
can't more manageable why oh dude that's
awesome
Thank You JD that's a great question and
I hope that that's a fix for you my
friend and I appreciate you calling it
and leaving that's a great one and also
I was thinking about you know the reason
why you're here today we thought about
like we just wanted to have like just
more norm just people in the world do
you know like it's just more fun
sometimes to talk to somebody that you
know not having to talk to like
celebrity or try to get solar just sure
it's it's fun to just I don't know
celebrity life is a little different for
sure yeah and um
just glad you're here today that's what
I'm trying to sell thanks man thanks for
having me and what I want to say is so
you talked about putting in that even on
Craigslist every now and then
yeah and that's how we found you yeah
like our our idea was just we want to
have somebody on we want a plumber yeah
let's let's do it we're trying to get an
illegal alien to come on nice so we're
like we want a plumber so we go on
Craigslist to look and because you put
your ad out there you are searching for
business you are doing your job then
that's how we found you right now yeah
and we were just talking about like
toilet champion at least website traffic
maybe it's not local people who can you
actually hire you but it's gonna blow up
and I bet you'll get some tpw fans in
the valley hitting you up I'm hoping
dude I'll Drive out there and [ __ ] and
call you but just the way that you put
yourself out there and get and work hard
man and that um and that's how we're
here today because you don't put that ad
out we don't even know about you right
right and this has been an amazing um
there's been an amazing time it was fun
just learning about it so real quick I
got a UH I told Nick this this story you
gotta hear it man it's it is the
funniest thing that has happened and
it's worth it I didn't want I want to
introduce it but I don't want to step on
it so I'm glad you said something all
right awesome so I moved I transferred
from roto-rooter Alabama to roto-rooter
Tacoma okay and this is the toilet
champion story no ok the toy I told you
that one that was just putting the
toilet together and winning a trophy and
a hundred bucks I had a case i
shouldn't've it off to you that I move
like I said transferred working for
roto-rooter in Tacoma and we get a new
dispatcher and the new dispatcher that
gets hired is going to come on on right
along with somebody excellent
so she can kind of learn or he can kind
of learn what we do in the field you
know variants yeah so this girl Nikki
she comes with me and we go you know
she's cute is she cute yeah she was cute
enough yeah she's great
yeah they were both big
you know that lazy susan so anyway she's
we go on you know two three four service
calls or whatever it was go eat lunch so
I I have kind of a rare form of colitis
and my stomach can just blow up at any
time
yeah it sucks it's it's weird to iron
you know but in all the years even with
bad guts and all that stuff I've never
used a customer's toilet because that to
me is just bad etiquette you know I'm
here to fix it I'm not here to use it
yeah but this instance I had to use it
but I couldn't because everything in the
house was completely stopped up their
toilets were full of water their tubs
with full of water everything they
needed their main sewer line on stopped
and I cannot hold this anymore you got
that boy on I got a [ __ ] so fierce I
know when I really asked him IRL to
start shaking that's when I can't take
it anymore I start sweating o it cuz
it's it's about to Hannah go out of your
body
yes yeah so what can I do I jumped into
the back of my roto-rooter van I grabbed
a bucket and I shat very explosively and
very loud with her sitting in the
passenger seat no way Nicky with them
tits smelling in here and every bit of
what was gonna bleed you tell her first
I said I'm really sorry I I don't know
what she's like just do it and she's got
the windows rolled down you could tell
she's not happy about it but she
suffered through it she said the worst
part was the people still had the
plumbing problem so after I finished
blowing up that bucket I had to leave it
there and go fix these people's plumbing
for another 30 minutes leaving her with
the bucket of [ __ ] in the car she got
out for most of it and just kind of hung
out outside I gotta get out get on your
father
so I finish I get the drain unstopped
and everything else I get back to her
rinse rinse out the bucket and clean it
all out and everything and we drive all
the way back to the roto-rooter office
in silence
not speaking to each other but so much
chatter going on we ended up living
together for three years she was my
girlfriend for a long time that is
[ __ ] like Miracle on 34th Street
obviously she didn't mind the smell of
my [ __ ] that bad guys so if you want to
talk about a man that's crazy how the
vulnerability of something people
together it right it really does I mean
could I have been more vulnerable in
that situation yeah you know I'm almost
in tears like I'm so sorry I have to do
this oh you know and what did you tell
her to look the other way was there any
rules you gave well you know in in a
service man you got that bulkhead wall
right behind the right behind the seats
so I mean it's a steel wall but there's
holes through it yeah so I mean she's
facing forward she she can hear
everything that's going on like good
shots she could probably taste
damn near tasty hey you can't do what
you kind of do do you got to do what you
got to do your crazy memory you're the
best that's awesome you been a plumber
for how long Brad I started when I was
20 I'm 43 really yeah you look like
Danielle two from our cartoons doesn't a
little bit yeah beautiful do you look
like this kid I grew up in named a and
you'll dude who ironically used to drink
off the hose he would he would put the
hose in his mouth he put the hose in his
mouth and then have you turned it on
even if it had been sitting there all
winter at first I was hit from that
[ __ ] hot hit right I don't mind the
taste of hose water it's all right but
not too hot hose water he didn't get
that [ __ ] hot it he would go sometime
and lay the whole hose in the yard bro
on the hottest day and let that [ __ ]
heat up for a couple days sometimes dude
writers get in there to boil yeah dude
he'll put him right to the dog bro why
just taste the Lord brother he was he
was about the spirit man you know he
just I don't
but unbelievable dude that you have bad
plumbing in your body and you deal with
bad plumbing in the world right and then
I became a cook so I could like deal
with it coming in and coming out full
service and Bradley Coski the toilet
champion of the valley and maybe of the
whole world dude
I think it's the trophy worldwide I
think so why not yeah I've never had
anybody try to take it away come take it
off and come take it come get this I
dare you I got insurance we will see you
in the [ __ ] streets man yeah thank you
for being here today man I'm so happy
your dad got to be a part of it and and
just an inspiration man working hard and
just doing what you do dude and we're
gonna pay you what I don't know what the
time is but we're gonna be 500 hours for
being here today with us and awesome
ya know we appreciate it man a lot of
our listeners are hard-working people
and and we're just happy to be
associated with you so thank you so much
hey you ever get any further questions
shoot them my way all and whatever I'm
gonna save your number certainly will
toilet champion thank you hey thank you
[Music]
oh but when I reach that round I'll
share this piece of my background I can
feel it in my bones but it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake myself
[Music]